hello everyone this is some sub team and
we've got some news for you 've probably
noticed that for the last few weeks we
haven't posted any new videos about
surviving in the online jungle and I bet
you've been wondering why in this video
we'll tell you what's been going on
behind the scenes and what's going to
happen next
we want to be honest with you guys and
here is the truth for the last couple of
months we felt like our channel was
going through crisis
everything that we've been working so
hard on over the last year and
everything that made our Channel Unique
among the YouTube Tech Community has
become so routine and we felt the same
vibe from your feedback we felt that we
needed to change
so what's going to change first of all
we're going to change the way we produce
the content instead of four short videos
a month we'll work on one big one and
each of our new videos will be unique
we know how much you love our
investigations and experiments so we
decided that there should be more of
these kind of videos on the channel
however typically these are the most
difficult videos to make and they
require lots of work from all the team
so we decided to focus on quality and
not quantity
in addition to our investigations we'll
also share with you more guides and
instructions about how to protect
yourself online as well as interesting
facts and up-to-date news about cyber
security
these kinds of videos will be in the
format of shorts meaning they're perfect
for watching on the way to work or when
you want to learn something new in a
spare few minutes
sadly our beloved hosts Bradley Emily
and Lucas are leaving us
this was a very difficult decision for
us but we feel like the format of crazy
backgrounds and elegant storytellers has
exhausted itself
so instead of the usual presenters we'll
have a new voice to guide you through
the dangerous online jungle
we know how difficult it can be to
accept change but stick with us and
we're sure that after a while our
decision will begin to make sense to you
and finally we want to be more open and
communicative with you our wonderful
audience
but whilst our team is mighty it's also
pretty small meaning that sometimes we
just can't reply to all your comments
and great ideas about our videos and
channel
therefore we've decided to turn to you
guys to seek volunteers who would like
to join our friendly team here at sumsub
if you've been dreaming of joining our
team for a long time then head over to
our community posts and look for the
requirements for joining the ranks of
our Jedis of the online jungle
Well for now that's all the news we have
to give to you
we at the sunsup team believe that
openness and honesty are the most
powerful keys to people's hearts and
hope that with this video we've brought
more clarity about the future of the
channel
we can't wait to start this journey with
you guys see you very soon cheers